elle s'est invitée aujourd'hui c'est
vous olivier rozenberg bonjour bonjour
vous êtes politologue professeur associé
au centre d'études européennes et de
politique comparée
sciences po merci d'être là ce matin
après une nuit j'imagine assez courte
pour commenter les résultats de ces
élections législatives ici en france
première question peut être plus
compliqué qu'il n'y paraît qui a
remporté ces élections
ce qui remporte c'est ce qui arrive en
tête en politique comme ailleurs donc
c'est la majorité sortante ce emmanuel
macron et ses alliés il n'y a pas photo
il ya des questions sur leur capacité à
gouverner en revanche aucun de leurs
opposants ne prétend la victoire pour
une raison simple c'est que les
oppositions sont divisés entre un flanc
gauche nos positions sur la gauche de
madame lacroix une déposition sur sa
droite c'est cette division d opposition
qui fait qu'il ya un vainqueur
incontesté à 20khz avoir contesté
effectivement mais on est très loin de
la majorité absolue pour la coalition
présidentielle majorité qu'elle avait
dans la mandature sortante est ce que la
france entre ce matin en terre politique
inconnue oui inconnu oui on a déjà eu
une majorité relative ans en france
était de 88 à 93 ont ça date un peu et
mais l'ampleur était pas a été passé là
là il manque 40 3 enfin il manquerait
selon les derniers chiffres 43 sièges de
députés pour avoir une majorité absolue
43 sur 500 577 et 5% c'est beaucoup en
fait et du coup ça pose vraiment la
question de la capacité à gouverner dans
ces conditions là voilà le mot qui
revient le plus fréquemment ce matin
notamment dans la presse on l'a vu tout
à l'heure c'est la france est-elle
ingouvernable est-ce que vous pensez que
ça peut être le cas où est ce que comme
pouvait le dire jean luc mélenchon il ya
encore quelques temps les résultats de
hier soir vont être l'occasion de re
parlementarisme régime qui est censé
l'être d'ailleurs
ces deux questions différentes repart le
manta risée ça suppose d'avoir un
parlement qui est un peu haut au centre
du jeu cela suppose pas un idéal de
fermeture d'ingouvernabilité on peut
avoir un régime tout à fait
parlementaire comme l'allemagne par
exemple qui fonctionne bien et qui est
pas est capable ok on a un peu tendance
nous associer le blocage et le
parlementarisme sais pas c'est pas
pareil est ce que la france va être de
gouvernable ou pas en fait il ya deux
questions il ya est ce que le
gouvernement peut chuter à la fin du
mois ou au mois de juillet la réponse
est oui mais pour ça il ya une condition
il faudrait que la gauche
le rassemblement national et l air vote
la même motion et la votent comme un
seul homme comme comme comme une seule
femme c'est pas impossible mais je pense
que ça va se faire comme ça ça se ferait
ça se fera sans doute s'il ya une vraie
crise politique en tout cas ça veut dire
que l air si deux opposants résolus qui
serait la nuit baisse et le et le rn la
droite française lr a dans ses mains
chaque jour chaque semaine la
possibilité de faire chuter le
gouvernement ce qui est tout à fait
nouveau alors effectivement parmi les
enjeux de la mandature qui conan qui
commence il y as pour éviter l'
immobilisme comment est ce que la
coalition la majorité relative
présidentielle va parvenir à faire
passer des textes de loi les
républicains qui donc comme à chaque
élection territoire plantations
territoriale est important de sauve les
meubles on l'a dit qui donc obtient 61
députés selon les chiffres du ministère
de l'intérieur
quelle va être la décision des élèves on
sait que sur cette question là d'une de
rester dans l'opposition pure ou au cas
par cas s'allier avec la majorité il y à
débat nous sommes et nous resterons dans
l'opposition dit christian jacob s'est
pas la ligne par exemple défendue par
jean-françois copé oui le problème enfin
le problème du point de vue de la
gouvernabilité de la france c'est que
les membres de l air qui seraient les
plus susceptibles de faire une alliance
de faire un accord comme ça se fait
ailleurs mais ses membres sont pour
beaucoup déjà partis sont déjà rejoint
macron il ya cinq ans où il ya oui ah
oui à six mois et ceux qui restent vont
se vendre très cher ce qui reste donc
peut-être pas se vendre du tout parce
que c'est des gens qui ne veulent pas
donc c'est un parti qui aurait été
davantage divisé sa à l'origine est
qu'il l'ait - qui c'est qui s'est
radicalisée le on touche là un problème
plus fondamental qui est que le les
règles du jeu en france avec le scrutin
majoritaire avec l'importance de la
présidentielle pousse à se singulariser
à ceux à s'autonomiser alors que les
résultats de l'élection pousserait à
faire une coalition donc on a le teint
résultat à l'allemande sans les règles
du jeu à l'allemande donc le on est
coincé pour ça ouais et est-ce que du
coup la france va faire enfin en tout
cas le parlement français peut faire
le peut se mettre à faire des choses qui
ne faisait pas jusqu'ici à l'allemande
justement ce qu'on connaît peu ici en
france des coalitions au sein de
l'assemblée si une coalition elles
seraient elles seraient moins au sein de
l'assemblée que entre les parties dans
les semaines qui viennent entre enfin
principalement heller et et la majorité
c'est supposerait qu'il se voit ses
supposerait qu'il constitue un programme
de gouvernement en se mettant d'accord
loi par loi les programmes en allemagne
par exemple peuvent faire 100 pages sont
très détaillés ça supposerait que les
deux jouent le jeu à la fois un parti
d'opposition comme comme l air qui
décide pour quelques années de plus est
dans l'opposition mais aussi à manuel
macron qu'ils acceptent de baisser ses
cartes de dire de s'engager sur ce qu'il
va faire ce qu'il a très peu fait
pendant cette campagne est de et de
faire des compromis deux questions
précises si vous le voulez bien avant de
poursuivre et peut-être d'évoquer les
résultats des autres partis ou
coalitions à d'abord sur la possibilité
que le président macron décide de
dissoudre l'assemblée nationale
peut-il le faire dans le très court
terme on entend depuis hier que la
constitution sur ce point est ambiguë
réponse non ambiguë il peut le faire
peut le faire quand il peut le faire
quand ils veulent et là où il peut pas
le faire c'est quand il vient de
dissoudre la il peut il doit attendre un
an maintenant il pleut il peut le faire
quand il veut simplement
on le sait un quand il ya une élection
lendemain d'une élection qui a déjà eu
lieu on a eu le cas en israël et en
espagne très récemment les résultats
sont les mêmes simplement parce que les
électeurs ont réfléchi avant d'aller
voter cette fois ci donc il n'a aucun
intérêt compte tenu de la
contre-performance du fait qu'il est
quand même arrivé premier il a ce sera
paris trop trop trop risqué que de le
faire maintenant autre point important
pour ceux qui nous regardent on pourrait
penser que le gouvernement serait être
encouragés à utiliser l'armé fatale du
49-3 pour faire passer en force des
textes mais là il y a une réserve
importante qui diffère justement de ce
qui a pu se passer à la fin des années
80 7ce 49,3 n'est utilisable que de
façon mesurée oui que pour un texte par
an en dehors des budgets en dehors des
deux bus j'ai donc ça limite la casse et
de toute façon quand on utilise le 49-3
on invite en fait l'opposition à faire
une motion de censure si elle est si
elle n'est pas d'accord et c'est un jeu
dangereux compte tenu de la situation
les 10 il suffit que les trois
oppositions
salies vote le même texte même s'allier
sur un sur un nom pour faire chuter et
forcé à la démission le le gouvernement
bornes du coup ça invite à ne pas agiter
devant eux le chiffon rouge du cac 40 à
l'issue de ces élections la nuque comme
le rassemblement national revendique le
rôle de premier opposant au parlement la
nuit pétanque une coalition avec ce que
ça peut impliquer comme désunion parfois
étant donné l'hétérogénéité de la
composition cette coalition qui
aujourd'hui est concrètement le premier
opposant à la coalition à la majorité
présidentielle à l'assemblée est ce
qu'on peut dire de façon neutre c'est
que la première coalition d'opposition
c'est la nuit le premier pas est le
premier parti premiers groupes
parlementaires d'opposition
ce sera le rassemblement national à la
surprise de à la surprise de tout le
monde ça veut dire par exemple s'il ya
des postes réservés à l'opposition la
coalition va être en meilleure situation
pour essayer d'obtenir les plus
importants d'entre eux les commissions
de la présidence de la commission des
finances
notamment parce qu' il peut y avoir une
coordination entre les filles les
communistes les écologistes et les
socialistes pour se répartir les postes
importants quelques mots du score
historique du rassemblement national
dont 89 députés c'est dix fois plus que
dans la mandature sortante il me sens
voire même plus que ça la nuque accuse
le camp d'emmanuel mâcon d'être
responsable cette percée inédite de
l'extrême droite que faut-il en penser
c'est en la défaite du président
maquereau ou la victoire du
rassemblement national ben on a on a
beaucoup de députés est reine par
rapport à ce qu'on a connu dans
l'histoire de france c'est le plus gros
score et en même temps il faut bien voir
que si on avait un mode de scrutin
proportionnel comme on l'a partout
ailleurs en europe sauf au royaume uni
on en aura encore plus on en aurait pas
le doubs mais mais pratiquement donc le
j'ai envie de dire si une banque avant
tout les électeurs qui ont choisi
d'avoir autant de deux députés et rennes
le mode de scrutin majoritaire
bloque les petits partis les partis eux
sans qu'ils sont isolés qui ne font pas
d'accord programmatique
mais jusqu'à un certain point et il ya
un effet de seuil et un moment donné
quand on se retrouve premier dans
beaucoup de circonscriptions beaucoup de
domaines en france on arrive à 90
députés c'était l'action cette élection
a acté à la mort du front républicain ça
pour le coup cette historique
je crois pas je crois pas parce que
la décision relève aussi des lecteurs
individuellement sans consigne de vote
avec des particules de moins en moins
d'autorité pour eux pour les données
donc il ya des électeurs pour qui la
fait encore beaucoup de sens de
s'opposer aux eaux et rennes et qui
continueraient à le faire on a vu dans
des duels rn nuque une grande majorité
par exemple des électeurs d'emmanuel
macron s'abstenir ce qui aurait pu ne
pas être le cas il ya encore quelques
années
oui oui mais
je pense que tout n'est pas dit et en
tout cas on a une droite qui elle est
reine qui si elles étaient associés
seraient aurait un score beaucoup plus
important donc on a toujours un arn
isolé qui par son isolement cantonne ses
résultats même s'ils sont importants
cette fois ci quelques mots de la nuque
maintenant donc 131 députés selon
toujours les chiffres du ministère de
l'intérieur un parent il a admis à demi
réussi mais réussit ou quand même bah
oui ils ont ils ont à peu près ils vont
avoir à peu près un quart des députés ce
qui représente grosso modo le poids
électoral de la gauche en france qu'à
énorme parce que parent on est loin de
la moitié comme on a pu connaître
pendant des années mais on va avoir une
proportion de députés à l'assemblée
nationale de gauche qui représente voilà
ce qui ce qui représente dans
l'électorat avec une domination en leur
sein de députés les filles nouveau plus
jeune parti vert socialement qui peuvent
amener une forme de renouveau mais aussi
des équilibres puisque y aurait
vraisemblablement
free y aura un groupe socialiste un goût
vert est probablement un groupe
communiste donc mais ce second tour
confirme ce qui a été le premier le le
gagnant le vainqueur enfin celui le
celui qui s'en sort le mieux de cette
coalition de gauche c'est là c'est la
france est soumise oui il était en
position de force pour négocier après la
présidentielle est long ils ont tiré ils
ont utilisé à plein en même temps ils
ont quand même sur et gardé à peu près
la moitié des circonscriptions un peu
moins à peu près là peu moins de la
moitié des circonscriptions de gauche
pour leurs alliés ce qui était la
condition de la non pas de la victoire
je vais faire un lapsus mais du fait
qu'ils s'en sortent ils s'en sortent
avec les honneurs avec un défi qui sera
celui de parler d'une seule voix
j'imagine qu'on en reparlera dans les
jours à venir juste un mot de
l'abstention
on est toujours que sur enfants inscrits
sur deux bons voire - qui a voté hier
oui alors que on le voit ces élections
sont cruciales et vont peut-être bloquer
la france pour les cinq années à venir
donc à une sorte de d'inadéquation entre
ce qu'on peut percevoir dans l'espace
public on se dit c'est la présidentielle
c'est là qu'on choisit le gaou la fille
importante pour diriger le pays le fait
que les élections qui compte en fait son
segment ce mobilisme le moins quelque
chose qui tourne pas rond système
politique et il n'y aura plus
d'élections en france avant 2000 j'ai un
trou mais avant plusieurs années ils
vendent c'est mal à 2022 sauf
dissolution sans la solution
effectivement merci beaucoup au lit